and now gang we'll find out who was
really behind the hauntings at YouTube
headquarters
wait gang I think this is another mask
yeah
no big no there hold on hold on jinkies
how many of these things are there
[Music]
alright alright I think this is the last
one the real person behind the hauntings
that YouTube HQ was liked commented and
imprison hello Internet welcome to film
theory the show inspired by Velma's
incredible ability to rationalize any
supernatural event simple fact is
monsters are nothing more than crooks
and masks usually unscrupulous real
estate developers so just over a year
ago I did my first episode on scooby-doo
in which I tried to calculate Shaggy's
power level and whether ultra instinct
shaggy was actually some sort of super
saiyan remember that meme that lasted
like a week good times anyway in my
research for that episode I've watched
an entire generations worth of new
scooby-doo episodes not just the
original scooby-doo where are you not
just what's new scooby-doo or heck not
even just the new scooby-doo movies but
all of the scooby-doo generations let me
reiterate that all the generations and
that my friends is no small feat
scooby-doo is a 14 series 36 movie
cannon spreading 51 years it's turned to
lose his mind and boy was that crash
course through half a century's worth of
cartoon can and a wake-up call for four
years I just assumed that shaggy Scooby
the gang were living out the same
Sisyphean note Meryl
time driving from town to town and a
barely functional van forced to solve
spooky mysteries that always always
amounts to some guy in a really
convincing rubber mask with way too much
special-effects technology on his hands
and what does the gang get for all their
hard work nothing maybe a sandwich if
they're lucky well except for that one
time that Scooby got himself a chest
full of Confederate money Fred and
Daphne are in a will they won't they
relationship Shaggy's romantic interests
fluctuate between Velma and Scooby as
dog insert wacky guest star here sorry
Batman they run off sometimes plate is a
natural response to the unknown can we
help you kids out and I wasn't entirely
wrong but I was binging through this
franchise I was shocked to learn that
across those 51 years those fourteen
series and those thirty-six spin-off
movies that there's actually a complex
scooby-doo lure here no joke long long
before the MCU there was the SDU it
might be easy to assume that each
iteration of scooby-doo is completely
separate from all the ones that came
before it because it helps chest a
cartoon right who's putting in that much
effort but in reality the teams behind
these shows appear to be taking a lot of
care with the long long long history of
this series so much so that the entire
franchise movies and all can basically
be boiled down into two self-consistent
timelines well two and a half if we're
being completely accurate at least
that's my theory today anyway so with
the new film entry coming out later this
week looking to set up a prequel story
that I guarantee will burn this theory
to the ground
I guess our new movie is an origin story
I may at least get the video out now
before it completely throws off all my
research so before we start throwing
things into timelines let me lay out the
major pieces first and most importantly
let's get the big one out of the way
scooby-doo is an alien period end of
sentence that is a hundred percent
canonical fact that isn't me even
overreaching in the slightest
in the recent series scooby-doo mystery
Incorporated which his shockingly lore
heavy for a Scooby show we learn about
the Anunnaki an ancient godlike alien
race that comes to earth every few
thousand years the Anunnaki have no
physical forms so the
forced to possess animal bodies the
Anunnaki have a great history of helping
humans but we have no physical form and
must inhabit animals this is why some
animals our descendants can talk and
others cannot so if we happen to know
any animals in this series that are
capable of talking or being understood
by humans well we can reasonably assume
that that individual is an alien
descendant
that's why scooby-doo can talk he's got
himself damn a lien genes the heart it
also explains one of his iconic
catchphrases so that's big reveal number
one about this series its lore and we
are just getting started
the mystery Incorporated series also
introduces us to the canonized concept
of a Scooby multiverse in the final
episode of this particularly interesting
run Scooby and his friends help defeat
an evil Anunnaki who's been trapped on
earth to try and escape this Force has
been assembling and manipulating mystery
teams throughout the ages to try and get
released with the Scooby Gang being his
most recent group of kids once this evil
entity gets destroyed however Scooby's
entire world gets destroyed along with
it launching the main mystery gang into
a brand new existence their same
hometown of Crystal Cove but with
everything slightly different shaggy is
no longer a slacker but rather a top
chef Velma is a champion academic but
perhaps most shocking of all Fred and
Daphne are engaged I know why
everything's different we destroyed the
entity and by destroying it
It was as if it never existed by
destroying the evil entity we created an
entirely different timeline our actions
created a better world where we all have
normal and productive lives so that off
the bat gets us into two separate
timelines same Scooby Gang carried out
across two branches of the multiverse
the next big issue that we need to talk
about are the monsters themselves the
vast vast vast majority of the shows
recycled the same twist there were no
ghosts man was the real monster all
along that was the formula for decades
for the TV show at least and yet for
some strange reason most of the movies
like 1987 scooby-doo meets the Boober of
and most of the directive video
scooby-doo movies like scooby-doo on
Zombie Island all have the gang
encountering real-life supernatural
creatures a very select few of the
series had this as well like the 13
ghosts of scooby-doo the Scooby and
Scrappy show and mystery Incorporated
where again the ghosts and boogie men
are actually real supernatural creatures
when I first encountered these outliers
I was just happy to write them off as
taking place in a totally different
universe in one universe ghosts are fake
the mystery gang always pulls off a mask
and everyone's happy and the other
ghosts are a real threat and we should
all be terrified by the retribution that
the undead shall deliver unto us here's
where things get weird though and many
of the ghosts are real iterations
shaggy wears a red shirt red different
shirt different universe obviously okay
now that might seem like an exaggeration
and normally it would be but there's
actually more to Shaggy's wardrobe
changes than meets the eye you see in
the 2001 direct-to-dvd movie scooby-doo
and the cyber chase the Scooby Gang goes
into a Scooby based video game world
complete with digital doppelgangers and
what does Shaggy's digital form look
like red shirt big deal right it's just
a physical color swap to differentiate
him from the real shaggy except that's
not the case look closer and you start
to see that the shirt isn't the only
thing different about Shaggy's digital
form his eyes are also different and not
just different they're the exact match
for how they were drawn during those 80s
era scrappy centric scooby-doo episodes
so could all of the ghosts and Ghoulies
from scooby-doo and the 13 ghosts and
Scooby and the scrappy show episodes
have taken place in a digital simulation
to know for sure we have to start
putting this whole thing together the
first thing that happens chronologically
is the birth of scooby-doo
in 1969 this is according to a fake
document that Velma uses to claim scooby
as a service dog in the movie legend of
the phantosaur which funny enough was
the same movie where ultra instinct
shaggy got his origin so across the
board probably the single most important
piece of scooby-doo related media to
ever come out in half a century
I can't tell if I'm exaggerating that or
not the rest of the gang was probably
Morna round the same time because of
Scooby's Annunaki heritage he actually
ages at a speed closer to that of normal
human
so roughly ten years after being born
he's still very much a puppy for the
events of the first series
chronologically in the ninth overall
series in the franchise to be launched a
pup named scooby-doo along with the
movie that was set in the same time
period into mystery map in the first
episode of the series we see the gang
already together in solving mysteries in
their hometown of Coolsville USA under
the name the scooby-doo detective agency
this series directly leads into the
original series scooby-doo where are you
and its many follow-ups the new
scooby-doo movies where they hang out
with celebrities before eventually
winding up with the scooby-doo show and
with that we come to the darkest period
scrappy-doo Scooby's nephew who was
deemed by censors as quote too
independent which apparently is a bad
thing to teach kids well at the time he
was popular enough to help prevent the
scooby franchise from being cancelled
since then he's become the single most
hated television sidekick of all time
even the creators of scooby-doo
themselves will only allow references to
him insofar as they make fun of how bad
he was unlike the previous incarnations
of the series this new iteration focuses
on dealing with real monsters and real
supernatural threats rather than your
typical villain hiding under a mask but
oh in a series that's only focused on
real-life crooks did supernatural forces
suddenly appear out of nowhere in this
world clearly there had to have been
something to prompt this change in the
world from the classic Scoobies
technological terror into the modern
Scoobies paranormal fears the answer
actually lies in a crossover episode one
that would happen three decades after
scrappy was first introduced a crossover
of supernatural proportions because it's
crossing over with the show Supernatural
now if you're unfamiliar with
Supernatural it's about you guessed it
the supernatural and two paranormal
hunters in the season 13 episode Scooby
natural something incredible happens for
both the supernatural and scooby-doo
universe's when the two collide brothers
Sam and Dean from Supernatural gets
sucked into the world of scooby-doo
along with their angel friend Cass but
here's where things get really crazy you
see they're not just sucked into the
world of scooby-doo they're sucked into
a real episode of the show specifically
the 16th episode ever titled a night of
fright is no delight which when it first
aired just ended with the typical bad
guy in a mask reveal however what were
shown in this crossover is that the
supernatural guys accidentally opened
the Scooby Doo universe up to real
paranormal powers them entering the TV
show has allowed a ghost in resulting in
the two hunters chasing an actual ghost
through an episode where there wasn't a
ghost to begin with meanwhile the
mystery yang stays oblivious to the
whole thing at the end of the episode
the Winchester brothers managed to
convince the Scooby Gang that it's all
been elaborate tricks and gadgetry
before that though the mystery gang does
get itself a little wake-up call from
Cass vampires I thought I was blind
without my glasses but I was just blind
that means that Scooby's supernatural
elements may have been brought into its
universe by the supernatural team when
they chased a ghost into the cartoon
that explains how later series in the
timeline with the scrappy-doo series and
the 13 ghosts of scooby-doo that follows
it we have supernatural beings suddenly
present out of nowhere in the Canon what
it doesn't explain away though is Velma
and Fred not knowing who scrappy is oh I
guess the gang's all here except scrappy
what's a scrappy sure they didn't share
that many episodes together but that
first season that scrappy appeared and
did have all the gang together for
multiple episodes it also had really
terrible animation for all those
episodes I mean look at shaggy looks
like he was put through the rack must
have been a gas leak season or as we
previously established it had to have
been in the video game simulation for as
crazy as it sounds it actually makes
sense the first season with scrappy
literally sees the gang week over week
going to Britain to Egyptian inspired
locales to California New York even
places as far-flung as Greece which
wouldn't you know it are exactly the
types of exotic levels that we see the
gang flashing through as we're trapped
in the video game sim from scooby-doo
and the cyber
chase so look on the plus side all you
scrappy haters a full one of his seasons
doesn't even count because it all took
place in a computerized simulation that
season along with at least three movies
scooby-doo meets the boo brothers you
guys are ghost exterminators scooby-doo
in the ghoul school and scooby-doo and
the reluctant werewolf totally don't
count at this point then we have to
remind our timeline math all the way
back to the beginning the very beginning
for our second alternate universe the
mystery Incorporated universe you see
televisions in the world of mystery
Incorporated still use a four by three
standard broadcasting ratio which
started going out of style in the mid
90s and would have been startling ly
obsolete by the time mr. Inc actually
aired in 2010 that means that this show
wasn't meant to take place concurrently
with the show's airing but rather
sometime back in the 80s and 90s because
the gang is back in high school again
it's most likely to take place in the
80s except this go-around all the
mysteries from the other timeline have
already been solved the first episode of
the series starts with Velma giving a
tour of the Haunted museum and it's a
who's who filled with nods to all the
classic monsters from scooby-doo where
are you not me they all turned out to be
fakes
that's not although we see the luna
ghost from the scooby-doo live-action
film as well as references to
scrappy-doo and never talking about him
again we all promised each other that we
would never speak of him not ever
so then why wouldn't this be connected
somehow to our main timeline well
because a they don't believe in real
ghosts win in the main timeline by this
point they've seen plenty of those be
there born and raised in a new town this
one's town is Crystal Cove as opposed to
Coolsville USA and see they don't
recognize Vincent van ghoul the wizard
who served as their guide throughout the
13 ghosts of scooby-doo and its spin-off
movie the curse of the 13th ghost it's a
paradox that can only be solved via
separate timeline at the end of the
series as I talked about earlier the
team is sent to a new timeline where the
supernatural entity never existed in the
first place when Fred arrives in this
new world upon realizing there's no dark
entity or the effects that it left he
declares that it's a
histories of course this is wrong but
what it does mean is that this is a
world without paranormal activity which
leads directly into the events of be
cool scooby-doo which sees our gang in
their new timeline we're told that they
just got out of high school which
continues the story of them being in
high school and mystery Incorporated and
true to what Fred said about a world
without mystery this new series moves
away from solving crimes and more into
the territory of Phineas and Ferb
complete with increased emphasis on
comedy and wacky inventions and that's
the latest point in the scooby verse as
of now given the show's tendency to jump
around its own timeline there's no
guarantee the next batch of Scooby
episodes and movies will even take place
in the future of the timeline maybe
they'll track back to when the gang was
in a more grounded seeming reality but
for once we can roughly see the way this
entire timeline links together one
mystery gang we've watched grow up since
they were kids a second mystery gang
that of themselves crossed dimensions
into a brand new timeline and a third
that's entirely digital and now with
that out of the way tune in next week
when I explain how Fred and Daphne still
haven't become an official couple after
all these years actually that's not an
episode at all I just said it as a joke
the next episode is absolutely Rick and
Morty anyway until then remember it's
all just a theory film theory
[Music]
you